[Music]
thank you all for coming and listening
to us
my name is Tino I work on Google
bigquery and we're gonna talk about some
interesting advanced topics namely real
time architectures real time tends to be
fairly difficult but it doesn't have to
be and so we worked really hard to make
that as easy as possible for you so
we'll go into that a little bit detail
further on but first let's hear it from
a customer who has gone through his
journey throughout the last four or five
years with us
please welcome Yuki who's the CTO of
plate Yuki please sixteen oh thank you
for taking time for our session
TripIt oh this is my second English
presentation in my life so I I approach
as in other bands if you cannot
understand or want to know more about
detail or my part please find me and
talk to me after the session I teach you
Japanese and talk in Japanese I am Yukie
Makino City / parade
I am I'm working in place and I'm in
charge of real-time data engine for
about four years and before since before
the read release of our service karta
today I'll show you our architecture
history and we carry usage pattern in
part ok
fred is a fast growing startup company
in Japan we provides real-time analysis
named Carter Carter has three
characteristics compared with other data
services a real-time process care and
grower Gruber and March tenant sorry
Carter it's a weird time Alex - so it
has data in there time and it has more
than or 500 interprets Cale Bryant and
so data bottom is we hundred is very
large and provinces isolated by data set
to share the data correctly - by cart a
- groans and some Japanese kron4 with
the data in foreign countries so we
destroyed our data to monitor March for
global region in bigquery okay Carter is
not only data visualization sir but also
actions so it will process data and
returns actions within one second so
it's really their time service using one
second it processes sixty sixty five
thousand events per second three billion
events per day and it is as one petabyte
streaming data being biased streaming
insert per month and the country we
stored stupid
modern two-bit a petabyte data in
bigquery and the modern 260 petabyte
honor is per month and we contracted
flat rate prom with six thousand throats
four thousand for us and 2004 japa
okay
as you can see this guillotine stuff we
use a big query Chevy very heavily and
this is why this is the reason why I
share our experience today okay so in
order to understand architecture Lee
actually I'd like to have a brief
introduction of court a court is a
website real-time on a customer Nordisk
on the action so we call it customer
experience brought home it is for
managing customer experience in website
to know real-time customer state and to
do appropriate action which suitable to
each other each user I'd like to show
more technical concept of the system
cartridge system concept is real-time
reactive system firstly individual sense
event to our system and karta on ERISA
currently user state based on four
events a user has said change the first
budget based on the calculator state it
returns appropriate options of the
reactions to the register event the
users hand and also our clients can see
the other user state and configure
options in the application in the
airtime Lacroix and said options to
segmented to users then the action for
some segments are started to fire
instantly I we started to use bigquery
about four years ago soon after our
first release at the time we is inserted
in event rotate about streaming insert
shimmery we use bigquery
just for all analysis at this moment
next face we started to use bigquery in
the production application their
directory to show analyze data to our
client
we also started to insert honor Aziza
stated in bigquery in order to aggregate
his estate in the application this is
current architecture we add new data
management functions so that our clients
can import and export data in bigquery
with data row and it can also export
data to spanner and big table to store
data in radish incense trail bigquery
actually sent up our data ecosystem not
only for us but only who our clients we
use bigquery in various way to realize a
theater analytics service all right so
today I'd Rock Show 5 the avatar and
bigquery usage pattern we use in
production system the hospital is
compressed complex query and cache
cutter this pattern is infertile client
application this pattern can be used
when you want to make her a little
time-consuming complex query in
production system in normal way when you
want to analyze data stored in data rate
or warehouse through application to the
production application you put ETL layer
and fetch data eater of the database
previously we use another eto database
to fridge analyze data but it's complex
and not fracture and a lot real-time
when we try to change access pattern we
had to change the ETL process and the
application call to fetch the data so we
broke it in memory cache layer in front
of bigquery and access it with Seco
transparently if we want to change the
access part
you just a secret eckists application
use it's very flexible in your case we
use harsh body all the sicko take this
as a key of cache entries if the Russian
Therese did not exist in church table
then it runs the query actually in
bigquery and create a new cache entries
okay sorry
however in this pattern cache missed
query takes some time so if you want to
shorten it's a fast query latency
optionally you can create cash are
synchronously
in background in advance and then you
can be this leadership or this is actual
production screen actually we use and
first pattern to show this view you can
see real-time data application it's
quick enough right small application
okay
The Next button is easier on simple
query pattern this pattern is also used
in front of current application when you
analyze data more interrupt will ease
bigquery this potency is for bigquery is
powerful so we store a full roll
everything to bigquery as data rec with
schema rest and JSON string the query in
us enough fast even for these kind of
raw data but if you want to do or a
little heavy it is heavy tasks such as a
passing rajasam joining multiple step
obligation it may take more than 10
second if you want to analyze this
schemers didn't or interrupt to be weak
really it ELT save inquiry is suitable
saving theory is very useful and fast
and simple saving carry saves query
results as a new table
you need you don't need any additional
system to do ETR on a year ot to see
real-time data real periodically it
exhausts key and the bodies from
rowdyism calculate are great the bodies
and merging into a simple summary table
okay
for example with saving freely it pasts
passage JSON log data on the aggregates
part is good reply user ID and please a
row having segments and stats of each
user and from production system its
application run simple query such as
intersection the query data sheet or
brick query for single query is bedroll
look right this super fast this is
implemented only by yearly the bigquery
table simply just next button is a
frequent up the draw draw pattern this
pattern is in streaming insert or user
data when you query for the register
data flow data this part is for it's a
very draw size of both sides and
cardinality not so Raj you just insert
all rows and query query the latest row
by using the string arc or row number
what if the average roadsides and the
card energy enlarge the course
ingredient streaming inside cause
storage cause scan cost becomes high so
we put perfectly to reduce cardinality
in front of sterling minute prophetess
does data to be inserted in conquer the
shorter let's say three minutes it's in
three minutes since roster entry and if
we're all having the same key comes it
just overrides all these and
enter his body after the three minutes
since the first entry the entry is
inserted to require it with strumming
insert by using this Baja key
it prevents to ride on this history all
the roads to be curly perfect you can
permitted by data flow or a memory cube
after we use in memory a skill that is
cute ok New Yorkers we use this pattern
who authorized user state data the
average of data straws data size is
about 200 kilobytes and we said
buffering time five minutes it's easy
800 terrible per month with this pattern
if we didn't abide espada the data size
would become ten times more so by using
this problem we need is a cost by 90%
the first part is optimized for already
she's having a pattern this pattern is
used for ready to change to rail when
you want to use data in bigquery
invitation good sensitive system you can
use this pattern data broker eg export
data in bigquery to as a DCP datastore
service including spammer big turbo GCS
and readies you know case we exported
attitudes perma on the big table to use
user in the relationship layer for
example we export such as membership
information and documenting information
stored in bigquery two graphs use a
state or make recommendation option span
on the big table our key body based data
store so if a scope of entries to be
fetch is small the lady she becomes very
goal so if we want to use data in
registry rotation system it is
reasonable to export data to these key
body vessel data straw and roast button
is typed Joanne Potter this pattern is
this pattern used client data management
radio if your customer has only repeated
their table data in bigquery you can
directly draw in it your data set over a
project if you get your data is riotta
and customers data is your the beer time
then joined data is also real time you
can control access right in data set or
aware so you should separate data by
each user each customer to share what
data set were shared then you can touch
share the data set with in Seco
directory don't need any operation cause
for import and export if you use
bigquery fraud raid zero additional cost
is required with his data linkage and
analysis if you care sensitive data
BBC service control helps you it can
control access write all the data in DCP
service DCP services in fine-grained
level ok directory important can do if
the target data set are located in the
same region in our case on the other
hand some people in Tokyo region use
including government financial services
and banking services is restricted to
store data in Japan by the company
policy and a neighbor export essential
data to foreign country in this case we
copy data from global region to
illustrate region or insert with solving
insert restricted region in advance week
interrupt us vision and Tokyo regions at
Tokyo leader growth rate we analyze data
in u.s. region basically and when we
want to analyze that we change to the
data we allow us in Tokyo leisure
ok I just shared
5br return patterns we use in product
production system this is the
rasterizing apart bigquery is a core our
analytic architecture as I showed and it
is not only large scale and high school
put data engine but also can be
important role in the earth time system
and it is suitable for global service
global scales scales are a strike karta
now it is the center of data ecosystem
who asks and all
or also who our customers started thank
you thank you Yuki
thanks for team played coming out all
the way from Tokyo to share their story
and share what they've done over the
past years but plates started out with
with Google and the query in you know
four years ago and they didn't start
with as you saw they didn't start with
the massive architecture that they have
today
they started slow and that's really the
message that I want to tell you guys is
that you don't have to reply for me you
don't have to reorganize things
real-time doesn't have to be hard you
can start with a very basic architecture
if you're building a brand new
architecture it doesn't have to be
difficult and if you have an existing
environment you can simply just put this
on top of that right so a very minimal
disruption of your existing environment
and this is actually probably top three
architecture for real-time analytics at
Google that's it right going from your
application using bigquery streaming API
which is awesome straight into the
quarry and your data elbows in real time
right and a lot of our customers do just
that and that's perfectly acceptable but
you can you know our services work
together well and everything is
extendable so you can continue to kind
of expand if you wish to do so so for
example if you have an IOT use cases or
mobile maybe you have gaming logs and so
on and so forth maybe it makes sense for
you to keep some intermediate state that
passes information back to the to the
end device in which case you might want
to use high performance low latency
database like BigTable or fire store we
actually built integration with
buffalo's you can actually query
BigTable data directly from query I'd be
moving it into the core and on top of
that as you saw with played you can
start using bigquery as an ETL or alt
tool itself right you can move data from
left to right cleanse it and rich it
in the query itself the next stage
potentially if you so desire is to start
thinking about a true real time
architecture right so you can start
thinking about putting a pop sabor
compla with Kafka in your architecture
comic as a shock absorber and then you
can use our excellent service Google
Cloud dataflow or you can use Hadoop or
spark or spark specifically on data proc
for real-time data processing to enrich
data to cleanse it to create reports in
real time moving that data into bigquery
using our streaming API again and
potentially enclosing it further so
things are getting more interesting and
you know as you developed there's more
and more options right you can take your
data from left to right and finally if
you know if you start to really want to
productize your architecture we have
services that allow you to you know to
control your security privacy access
controls network on so on so forth and
including orchestration so all of these
things are kind of fairly flexible right
but let's talk about one specific
pattern here and that is once your data
is in bigquery a storage what can you do
with it especially what can you do with
it that doesn't have to do with the
things that the query provides right so
we've built standard sequel with lots of
lots of extensions that allow you to
express your logic just in playing
sequel we built UDF's user-defined
functions that allow you to go a little
bit beyond them we also introduced
declarative bigquery machine learning in
sequel and geospatial capability in the
last year and so all these things kind
of allow you to do a lot of things on
the query storage but as long as you are
bound by these processing terms but of
course you're gonna say Tino how come
you know I I have lots of other things I
want to do with my data but it's already
in bigquery storage what are my options
right so whether you're using languages
like Python Java or go maybe you have a
Jupiter notebook or Zeppelin maybe
you're using different libraries like
canvas or care ass or different you
should be reprocessing frameworks like
spark or flink what are your options
right the data is already
not a warehouse what can you do with it
well there's a couple of them right one
is maybe your data warehouse allows you
to put agents into the data warehouse
you you can part run third-party code in
there or maybe you can move data what
kind of read data from storage directly
so trickling data out or maybe you can
bulk export data which is kind of this
uncontrollable monsoon of that so to
recap the options are you can trickle
that out just by using a list API write
your paginating over data which can be
about 20 megabytes a second in the query
so it's real-time but it's very slow
it's not parallelizable you can bulk
export which is decisive in that
real-time it requires the middleman like
Google Cloud Storage it's probably going
to take you you know thousands of
minutes to hours to move lots of data
out of the query so maybe it's not
suitable for some of the more real-time
use cases and finally we're not going to
let you have third-party agents running
in the query it's just the security no
no right it's it's just something that
we can't do right so no good options
right and ultimately when you think
about it your data warehouse storage
typically is kind of locked out right
your your storage is locked away behind
a castle with a huge wall and a moat
around it and yeah you you kind of don't
have a lot of options and I guess a
quick segue I was going to use a real
image for this slide but I couldn't get
rights to it so I went on Twitter last
week and I asked folks to write a to
draw a picture and this is the winner of
the contest and the good news for me is
this this happens to be my boss's wife
so it's good hopefully I get a promotion
out of it but there is one worker out
that that we see in the wild out there
right if you have that and ubiquity
storage or other data warehouses you
could potentially keep a copy of that
data you know what a cold data Lake
storage it could be GCS it could be HDFS
you could use park' files or org files
but this is a little complex right it
allows you to to leverage these non
the quarry processing systems on top of
your storage but it's twice the
complexity twice the cost twice the
vibrational headache we feel like we can
do better
so I'm gonna pose the question is what
if you could treat your data warehouse
storage like like a data link like
storage really what would that look like
well I have an answer for you and we
launched something called the McCrory
storage API this is solve this exact
problem let's talk about that some more
so the quarry storage essentially allows
you to read data because storage API
allows you to read data from bigquery
storage at low latency writes one second
to first byte it's highly parallelizable
so you know as if you have something
that's reading from that's distributed
that's reading from the quarry storage
API you will have some really serious
throughput and we measured you know
multiple dozens of Giga bits per second
and it's also very flexible so you can
take advantage of the queries call them
their formats and so on and so forth
right so it's it's really useful and it
allows you to do that non bigquery
compute native processing on top of the
query storage and with that I'd like to
welcome Cerf who is a developer advocate
engineer he's going to talk a little bit
more about this and give us a demo as
well stuff thanks Dino so those of you
coming from other data where's
technologies like when you're dealing
with your data warehouse storage you're
dealing with a lot of complexity like
you have to deal with file system
layouts how you map storage to nodes all
sorts of kind of indexing and vacuum
strategies there's all this kind of
management overhead that goes with
maintaining your data warehouse and when
we built bigquery we thought maybe the
thing to do is to provide an expert to
every user and we do that by managing
your storage on your behalf you don't
have to worry about all these low-level
issues and you can focus on deriving
insights from your data as quickly as
possible
so let's talk about what it actually
means to be bigquery storage our primary
abstraction is the notion of a table and
when we present a table to you we focus
we focus your interests on like the
things that matter for your for your use
cases you define schemas so you set us a
you tell us what kind of columns are
available on your table what kind of
typing information we have a lot of type
functionality so you can do things as
simple as strings fixed precision
numbers floating-point bytes geography
types we also support complex data types
like struck structures and arrays you
also provide information that's useful
for you the consumers of your tables so
you provide descriptive metadata about
the tables themselves any information
you want to relay the users of the
tables about what's actually what's
what's actually contained in these
columns like how should I use this data
there's access control policies data
lifecycle policy so you can decide like
wind wind should data age out of this
table am I am i setting up for a world
where I retain all information
indefinitely or do I want to maintain a
sliding 90 day 365 day window that tells
me you know as data ages out remove it
from the table automatically I don't
think about it
the final thing you do is you provide
hints to us through the notion of
partitioning and clustering that
basically tell us these are the kinds of
access patterns I'm going to use with
this data and we use that information to
speed up access for you when we look at
a table we see a much different view so
we take everything from that first slide
and that's basically the user metadata
and then we're doing all the tracking
for everything else that happens in the
system so bigquery supports what sonoda
is is a snapshot isolation model so at a
given point of time we know what data is
is available in the table and what's not
and so we maintain all the all the
information about this data arrival data
leaving we also have to deal with all
the replication on your behalf so you
don't ever have to
about where's my data do it is it fully
replicated that's all handled for you as
I said earlier the lifecycle information
so we know at a granular level what
storage should be arriving and leaving
the table internally we also have a
bunch of other stats for understanding
operations that mutate storage so in
addition to that metadata layer where do
we actually put the contents of your
table like where as where is the where
is the data for your table itself held
we've talked about this in some blog
posts previously so we use a columnar
format for your data called capacitor
and what that does is it provides us
very fast ways to access your data such
that it supports kind of analytic
workloads so as opposed to like a
transactional system where you're doing
a lot of frequent mutations for
individual entities in an analytic data
warehouse you're scanning a lot of rows
at any given time we also so as this
diagram kind of shows the in addition to
grouping bait grouping data based on
transactional operations we also group
on a higher level abstraction of the
partitioning information and so what
that effectively means is whenever we
want to read a table we end up with a
set of columnar files that we need to
operate on our query engine basically
opens all these up simultaneously and so
what we've done is we've tried to figure
out a weight so that you can do very
similar things essentially what we want
to present is the ability for you to act
as a query engine so on the Left as you
see we have the you've selected you know
some set of you know you've selected the
table or partition and you want to read
that into your external application we
deliver that through a set of streams
and then we do decoding on the on the
client side so in comparison let's talk
about what what you could do today as
Tino mentioned we have the table data
list mechanism
which is a paginating cursor method so
it's a rest api which means you're doing
in individual discrete HTTP requests and
responses for each page of data you have
all this off flow to get through and the
data is presented to you in a JSON
format so it's not particularly
efficient at scale
by contrast the storage API does a
couple different different things to
handle this on the network layer we use
G RPC and streaming RPC protocol to
ensure that the latency for just moving
data back and forth is as low as
possible and we use a lot of flow
control to make sure that data is
continuously arriving we use a binary
serialization format so those of you
that are familiar with format or formats
like Apache Avro you will be reading
Avro out of these streams we're also
looking at other delivery formats so
feel free to catch me after the talk and
tell me like your favorite format and
why and we can we can look at what we
want to do that we also know this
abstract concept of a stream to deliver
data and that's our unit of parallelism
so streams make it easy easy to build
consumer applications based on the
notion of your architecture rather than
our architecture we didn't want to ship
a bunch of complexity around
understanding our low level storage
interfaces and so we built this
abstraction for you so when you when you
set up a session you basically tell us
basic information about what kind of
data you want to read properties of the
table how you want to access it and
importantly the parallelism you want to
read it at even a single stream is
generally more performant than the new
method simply due to the aid that the
technology changes as you you know are
able to scale up across multiple nodes
you can establish additional streams and
your throughput goes up as well and you
can keep doing this the basic bounds you
have are how much bandwidth you have a
bill
do you have the compute capacity to do
the decoding and what is the underlying
parallelism of the table you're
accessing so a very small table may only
be represented by a single file so
you're not able to use more than a
single stream to access it by contrast
as Yuki mentioned like they may have
terabytes to petabytes of data that
could be represented by hundreds or
thousands of collander files and so your
parallelization factor scales is the
amount of data scales so the the other
thing to keep in mind is we don't we
don't make you reason about which files
are going into which streams we do a
dynamic dispatch so that essentially all
you have to worry about is the stream
and we will make sure that it is
delivered to the streams and it we
allocate things in a safe way so you
don't have to worry about duplication
due to the the network transport however
you're dealing with distributed systems
distributed systems fail they just do so
how do you deal with that when accessing
your storage through this API so we
essentially present three levels of you
know recovery and error control so each
of those streams has an offset mechanism
so if you have a bad read you can
basically restart at the last point you
had a good read and couldn't and
continue on if for a for example here if
like your receiving node failed and you
need to restart the entire stream that's
perfectly legitimate as well and say you
had a much more catastrophic failure you
can restart the entire stream and we
will deliver the data in the same same
order we did in in the original session
one thing to keep in mind though many
applications are inherently single node
a lot of people have tools that just run
on a local machine
as long as you have sufficient capacity
on that machine it's perfectly okay to
fan in multiple streams onto that worker
one thing to keep in mind there is no
ordering guarantees B for each element
of the stream
so you can't say stream one's gonna get
a through its around etc so when we
think about the storage API we want to
give you the same capabilities we give
it we give our query engine which means
projection filtering if you only want
two or three columns out of a very wide
schema we will only deliver you those
columns that speeds you up because
obviously we're not sending that over
the network and we're able to leverage
our columnar format so it's very fast
for us to do this similarly you can
establish row size filter or row filters
to say I would like to throw away any
data on the server side before it even
comes across to the network so that my
might consuming application doesn't have
to even look at it and you can do that
as well so as I mentioned so we have a
snapshot isolation mechanism this is
sometimes called time could our time
travel in our system so we also give you
the ability to say I would like to read
this table as a midnight yesterday or
three hours ago cases where you might
want to do this if you you know just
recently did like a big DML update and
changed a bunch of your data and went
wait what was the state of that table
before I did that you can walk me what
you can walk before that event similarly
if you're doing like simultaneous reads
of a bunch of tables and you want a
coherent point in time for all three of
them or however min you're reading you
can set the snapshot time for all of
them to be identical so if I could
switch to the demo real quick
so one thing to keep in mind is I'm
terrible at visual demos so what we'll
be doing today is I'm going to
demonstrate like comparing the use of
the existing API to the new API and
we're going to use some data from the
public data program the public data sets
program and in this case what we're
going to be working with is something
called the sample commits table so it's
basically a subset of all the commit
history in github open source projects
restricted to some subset of the
available projects and we do that
because the whoops the raw data is 753
gigabytes and we can demo it but it will
be a much longer demo session this one
by a contrast is only about two and a
half gigs a couple hundred thousand rows
and so let's look at essentially I have
three nodes here the GCE VMs absolutely
vanilla that I've just put a variant of
debian on so to set the stage top box is
the existing cursor method it's it's
gonna move but it's not going to move
particularly fast so if we switch to the
storage API and a single stream we're
doing a little better we're certainly
going to arrive at the end before before
the first one so let me stop that and
let's paralyze it some more so my my
beautiful bark bar chart each color is
the data being delivered to a specific
stream so with a parallelism factor of
four we're moving a little faster
and stop that make it bigger
add more streams and unfortunately uh
text demos aren't the greatest for
visuals but low level storage api's
don't inherently make for great visual
demos I'm sorry so let's do one more
thing so in addition to that we talked
about the fact that you can do column
projections so if we say we're only
interested in the actual commit hash and
the the author's email address the
addresses are anonymized so we we lose
the identifier but we keep the domain so
if X in this data set a little faster
and last thing we can do is say
so this bar chart doesn't look very
pretty because we're filtering almost
all the data out as you can see we
apparently this is the equivalent of a
count star query on the table where we
say where is domain suffix is like that
filter so we have apparently 6000
commits in the github data and as you
can see we're still waiting on table
data to make its way to the end of the
table that's all I had for the demo
could we switch back to the screen now
I'd like to yeah you know turned it back
over to you and I'll go sit down over
here yes Wow
fantastic thank you so much stuff so yes
I think between hand drawings of castles
and text demos we've really raised the
bar here but the point stance it's a
really really fast API and you know as a
product manager I like to slide a lot
and hopefully as a customer or as a user
of the course to our JPI you like it as
well so it's it's a beta it's out now go
start using it there are still some
things that we want to do to get it to
GA but it's already out there it's
already highly useful so how do you use
it well one is if you have data proc
running or Hadoop or spark
we have released and are continuing to
release a number of connectors so for
example hive MapReduce spark cycle or
you can actually even can just create a
panda's data frame that is powered by
bigquery storage this is really powerful
because for one the patterns I've
described before you no longer have to
do that and two is you don't need to
sample your data and reduce it on your
bigquery storage before loading into
pandas you simply have a data frames
that runs on top of the core storage
okay great
the next one is if you're using data for
which is incredibly powerful unified
batching stream processing engine you
can read data out of bigquery storage do
some enrichment from third-party sources
maybe pops up and put it back into
bigquery storage you're using our
real-time streaming API so now you have
a real-time ETL processing system so the
data flow connectors out there you can
start using it today
finally odbc jdbc right there's some
good examples of tools that could be
potentially be benefiting from this
we've already updated the JDBC driver
and ODBC is coming very shortly right so
you just get a quantum leap of
performance if you're using any
third-party tool that relies on mass or
you your programmatically connecting to
the query using ODBC or JDBC and finally
it's a set point it's an API so you can
start using it just go and start
building code on top of it and we'll
have client libraries and all the good
stuff that you used to relying on and
we'll continue to expand on this
ecosystem so it's uh pointed out if you
have some requirements if your interests
and other things that could work on top
of the Cori storage API please let us
know we're really excited to build all
that and so I kind of give you a
whirlwind of different patterns that are
possible here and and you saw some of
them live with with played but but this
is just a sampling right this is not
everything that we can give you but I'm
really excited to tell you that that one
pattern of your data being in the core
storage is now we feel like is very
unique and it's very powerful and we're
looking forward to hearing how our
customers are using this we already have
a couple of users of this API Mixpanel
catalytics which are kind of similar to
play they're marketing analytics
providers and they're using this as
scale and it's kind of opened up a new
way of doing things it's much simpler
than the old ways it allows a cleaner
architecture in general
[Music]